welcome back everyone it's not just
government plans and vaccines that will
feel recover it's also the American
spirit joining me now to discuss that
author of the will while the book series
and Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo
Raymond just you've got some thoughts on
this I'll just hand it over to you go
for it
you know Steve I've been reflecting
during this period on our founding the
first revolution you're always carrying
the banner of the next one the first
revolution the spirit of recovery that I
think we've missed somewhere along the
way is found in our past in 1775 when
George Washington and our founding
fathers were struggling for independence
in Boston there was a smallpox outbreak
people forget about this he had his his
army was threatened all of Boston was
infected with this horrible contagion
here's what he did he quarantined the
soldiers and the Boston locals who were
infected and they moved forward with the
siege of Boston so he was fighting two
enemies the smallpox and the army he was
trying to repeal forgive us Steve your
countrymen then later we had had yellow
fever
people forget Alexander Hamilton in 1793
he contracted yellow fever in
Philadelphia he left the city he
recovered and the founding fathers found
a way to adapt they were innovative they
tried to contain the contagion that they
had no really therapeutic and certainly
no vaccine for they eventually
inoculated themselves very crudely but
when you look at the historical pattern
here yellow fever in New Orleans where I
am tonight a hundred and fifty thousand
people died between 1803 and the civil
war here but when Theodore Roosevelt
came he said New Orleanians through
creating greater drainage systems here
they built the the drainage system we
have today mosquito control he said they
took hold of it after it had started and
they controlled it and conquered it and
it seems to me we have to have that
notion to not focus on the the contagion
but on the goal of Liberty Steve that's
what always drove these great innovative
Americans forward and it reminded me of
John Adams whom himself battled smallpox
he wrote
in 1765 liberty must at All Hazards be
supported we have a right to it derived
from our maker and if we had not our
fathers have earned it and bought it for
us at the expense of their ease there
are states their leisure and their blood
today we're willing to trade that
Liberty Steve I worry for a quickie
pizza and a Netflix subscription our
Liberty is more valuable than that we
have to strive for it either
innovative ways to be safe and move on
with our lives I just really well said
and by the way Raymond you're reminding
me what I love about this country why
I'm so proud to be here literally why
I've decided to become an American
citizen and by the way I don't take the
British stuff the old British stuff
personally at all because my parents
were Hungarian immigrants all that old
stuff that wasn't my people okay so you
can be rude if you like about your
absorbed am exactly all right I thought
that was really beautifully put let's
bring in Lisa and Charlie Charlie start
with you what were your reactions there
to Raymond's thoughts well look
Raymond's exactly right the pursuit of
liberty is paramount for our country
recently Mayor Eric Garcetti said you
have to earn your freedom back think
about the significance of him saying
that no no no we have freedom naturally
we have natural rights that's the whole
point of our country is that the
Declaration of Independence the birth
certificate of our nation said the laws
of nature and nature's got it was a such
a categorical difference of saying no no
no you the government we actually create
you as human being so we have natural
rights in the state of nature and what
we see right now is we have to get back
to that pursuit of Liberty away from
this authoritarian technocratic nonsense
where they say two people in a boat you
can't go on wet sand you can no longer
skateboard people know this doesn't make
sense
it's Liberty that made America great we
have to get back to it well Lisa that's
right but the problem is isn't it that
the the actual recovery if we've been
realistic that's in the hands of state
and local politicians not all of whom
share these views by a long way right
well absolutely I mean I have Morphy
in the American people with exercise
common sense than I do any of these
politicians in these elected officials
and I I'm frustrated because what
frustrates me so much is so many of the
problems that we are facing are
self-inflicted they're done by
politicians who have locked down the
economy pushed off things like what was
non-essential health services and a lot
of these policies could potentially lead
to more deaths and destruction than the
coronavirus itself further I don't know
about you but I am so sick and tired of
people saying things like we're all in
this together
the most of the people who are saying
that are still getting a paycheck or
they're independently wealthy and it's
the 36 million Americans who don't have
jobs or the people is a hundred thousand
businesses that have permanently closed
in the business owners having their
dreams crushed or the mom and dad happy
to go to a food bank for the first time
in their life that are suffering so I
just find myself you know so frustrated
but I am confident that we will get
through this because the American people
are resilient and were strong but I have
more faith in the American people that I
do in any of those politicians well well
I mean Raymond I will hand it over to to
close this out but actually what lisa is
talking about there that righteous anger
that she's feeling and a lot of us she's
right that's part of the American story
too isn't it
no we're rambunctious people are defiant
people who were so committed to liberty
and freedom and I worried we were
trading that to stay at home in hiding I
have to tell you and I love being a New
Orleanian here in New Orleans you see
that spirit coming out even though we
have a mayor who's also locking things
down there's outdoor dining people are
developing UV masks Steve that have the
UV light that goes out so it purifies
the air on the way and that's the kind
of innovation and determination that are
going to get us back to living look we
made it through the Spanish flu the
yellow fever the smallpox we can make it
through the coal but it's not nearly as
deadly as those pandemics America's been
here before and we'll conquer this one
too and take hold of it as Theodore
Roosevelt said there you go great thank
you so much great discussion a really
important discussion now I really
enjoyed it thanks to all of you